Mon équipe et moi avons fait face à deux grands scandales en août 2009.
Le premier fut l'arrestation, le jugement et la condamnation
suivis de l'incarcération du très populaire maire de Détroit.
Le second entraîna la fermeture du labo scientifique de la police de Détroit.
Je pensais que rien d'autre ne pouvait mal tourner.
Puis le téléphone a sonné.
(Rires)
C'était le chef-adjoint de mon unité spéciale pour les victimes,
essoufflé à l'autre bout du fil.
Il me dit : « Chef, vous n'allez jamais croire ce que je viens de voir. »
J'ai eu un mauvais pressentiment, une boule au ventre,
car instinctivement j'ai su
que Détroit s'apprêtait à subir son troisième scandale d'envergure,
en à peine plus d'un an.
Il venait de visiter ce qu'il pensait être un entrepôt abandonné
dans lequel la police de Détroit stockait des preuves.
À l'intérieur,
il y avait 11 341 tests de viol abandonnés et non analysés.
Certains dataient des années 80.
Et certains ont maintenant plus de 40 ans.
Ces tests de viol débordaient de gros sacs poubelles noirs
et de barils de pétrole vides.
Chacun d'eux représentaient une victime,
pour la plupart, une femme,
qui avait subi une agression sexuelle brutale.
Chacune d'elles a volontairement enduré un examen de plusieurs heures
dans l'espoir que grâce à cela, son agresseur soit retrouvé.
Et sans qu'aucune d'elles ne le sache, aucune des 11 341 victimes,
ces tests de viol ne furent jamais analysés.
Je ne peux même pas décrire -- Oh !
Et d'ailleurs, avant d'aller plus loin,
durant cet intervalle de 40 ans,
ces agresseurs ont ainsi pu continuer à violer en toute impunité.
Je ne peux même pas vous dire à quel point j'étais indignée, en colère et furieuse.
J'ai moi-même été la victime d'une agression sexuelle,
Il y a très longtemps, pendant mes études de droit.
Je suis aussi mère de trois filles : une de 21 ans et deux jumelles de neuf ans.
J'étais encore plus horrifiée d'apprendre, si tant est que cela soit possible,
que le test de viol le plus ancien,
l'un des plus anciens, était celui d'une petite fille de 8 ans.
Je vais vous raconter son histoire, mais je vais l'appeler Natasha.
Le 2 janvier 1990, Natasha était chez elle quand un homme a frappé à sa porte.
Cet homme connaissait le quartier
et il connaissait les allées et venues de sa famille
mais Natasha ne le connaissait pas.
Il lui dit que sa grand-mère, la seule mère qu'elle ait connue,
avait eu un terrible accident,
qu'elle était allongé chez lui sur un canapé et réclamait sa présence.
Natasha, terrifiée à l'idée de perdre sa grand-mère, le suivit.
Mais bien sûr, nous savons que sa grand-mère n'était pas là.
Après avoir isolé Natasha, qui avait 8 ans,
il a commencé à la violer brutalement.
Il l'a violée avec sa bouche, ses doigts, son pénis.
Et il a même forcé son pénis dans sa bouche.
Quand il a fini, il lui a ordonné de se rhabiller,
il a fait de même
et il lui a bandé les yeux.
Et il l'a conduite dans une zone industrielle en limite de quartier.
Il lui a ôté le bandeau
et lui a demandé si elle savait rentrer chez elle.
Lorsqu'elle a acquiescé, il l'a laissée et il est parti.
Le viol de Natasha a été signalé immédiatement
et on a utilisé un kit de test.
L'examen avec le kit de test de viol terrifie et traumatise les femmes adultes.
Pouvez-vous imaginer ce que c'est pour une fillette de CE1,
qui portait encore des nattes et qui croyait encore au Père Noël,
de subir cet examen ?
Son test de viol est resté sur une étagère de cet entrepôt abandonné
pendant 26 ans.
Pamela, 19 ans -
je l'appelle Pamela, ce n'est pas son vrai nom -
19 ans, marchait dans la rue
après avoir rendu visite à son petit ami.
Elle a été attrapée par derrière
et a senti ce qu'elle a pris pour un pistolet contre ses côtes.
On l'a emmenée dans une maison abandonnée,
dans une chambre remplie d'ordures.
Chaque fois qu'elle se débattait,
il la frappait au visage et à la tête.
Il l'a violée brutalement sur le sol
de cette chambre couverte d'ordures.
Quand il a fini,
il s'est rhabillé,
a volé l'argent de Pamela et est simplement parti.
Elle aussi a aussitôt signalé son viol.
Elle aussi a dû subir un test de viol.
Et comme Natasha, son test de viol a attendu sur une étagère, pendant 15 ans.
Les criminels, tels que ceux qui ont violé Natasha et de Pamela,
laissent souvent leur ADN sur la scène de crime.
Pour une victime d'agression sexuelle, la scène de crime est leur corps.
Nombreuses sont celles qui décident de passer ce test interminable
qui nécessite que chaque centimètre et chaque orifice du corps de la victime
soient fouillés, prélevés et photographiés.
Tout ça, juste après une violente agression sexuelle.
Ce qui pousse les victimes à faire ces analyses,
c'est qu'elles veulent que la police scientifique les analyse.
Et qu'elle en tire un profil génétique
qui permettra d'identifier l'agresseur.
Quand la police scientifique trouve cette empreinte génétique,
elle l'entre dans la base CODIS, pour trouver une correspondance.
Le CODIS est rempli de profils génétiques d'individus ayant été arrêtés
et/ou inculpés pour certains types de délits.
Si un profil génétique est entré dans l'interface CODIS,
cela peut permettre d’identifier un agresseur en quelques minutes.
CODIS est l'acronyme anglais de Système d'Index d'ADN Combiné.
Alors, comment en est-on arrivé là ?
Détroit n'avait plus de fonds.
Au moment où on a découvert ces kits,
le coût s'élevait jusqu'à 1 500 dollars par kit
pour les faire analyser.
Je vous laisse calculer combien cela allait coûter.
En plus de ça, quatre ans après avoir trouvé ces tests de viol, en 2009,
Détroit était la plus grande ville dans l'histoire des États-Unis,
à déclarer faillite.
Nous ne savions plus quoi faire.
Ce n'était pas tout.
En commençant à étudier et à chercher comment ça avait pu arriver,
nous avons découvert qu'il y avait plus que de simples problèmes financiers.
Pendant les décennies où ces tests restèrent dans cet entrepôt,
on a appris qu'il y avait eu de nombreux changements à la tête de la police,
avec différentes priorités et différents objectifs.
La formation des agents en charge des crimes sexuels était très insuffisante
dans la police en général.
Ils étaient continuellement en sous-effectif
et manquaient de ressources.
De plus, il existait une culpabilisation perpétuelle des victimes
lorsqu'elles venaient signaler leur viol.
C'est la culture du viol.
Et à cause de cette culpabilisation
envers une victime d'agression violente,
certaines victimes ont même été ridiculisées
pour les dissuader de déposer plainte.
Bref, 11 431 tests de viol attendaient.
Je voulais de la transparence.
Je me suis demandé : « Que faire pour éviter que cela se répande ? »
Je ne veux pas faire tout ce travail pour que, dans cinq ou dix ans,
le même problème réapparaisse.
À cette époque, les officiers de police pouvaient décider seuls quand analyser
et de faire analyser ou non, les tests post-viol,
ceux dont ils avaient la charge.
Cela devait changer.
Nous devions les empêcher de décider par eux-mêmes
et faire voter une loi
pour s'assurer que chaque test de viol confié par une victime à la police
soit analysé immédiatement.
Je savais aussi que nous devions créer un autre système
pour garantir l'honnêteté et la responsabilité de chacun,
qui nous permettrait de localiser ces tests à tout moment.
La solution était simple.
Pensez à ces centaines de milliers,
et peut-être des millions de paquets,
transportés par des sociétés de distribution chaque jour.
Ils sont scannés et tracés
et les sociétés connaissent chacun de leurs déplacements,
du moment où ils entrent dans l'entrepôt,
jusqu'à ce que le colis soit livré à la porte de l'acheteur.
Pourquoi ne pas faire de même pour les tests ?
Je ne voulais pas réinventer la roue.
Alors j'ai contacté UPS.
UPS, en deux semaines, deux semaines,
après notre première réunion avec eux,
nous ont présenté un programme ambitieux
impliquant toutes les parties prenantes :
agents de police, procureur, structures médicales,
médecins légistes, hôpitaux,
personnels des labos et avocats.
Tous pouvaient connaître l'emplacement des analyses, à tout moment.
Ils ont mandaté des experts
pour quadriller Détroit, parler aux parties prenantes,
établir un plan
et étudier l'itinéraire des tests,
à partir de l'examen médical,
jusqu'à l'analyse en laboratoire
et renvoyé au personnel de la police.
Ils ont aussi créé un portail internet
où toutes les parties peuvent voir où se trouve n'importe quel test
à n'importe quel moment.
UPS avait la technologie,
UPS savait l'exploiter pour résoudre notre problème
et nous pas.
Nous avons lancé -
nous, c'est UPS et le bureau du procureur -
(Rires)
nous avons lancé un programme pilote à Détroit.
Et nous avons commencé le processus le 28 janvier 2015,
jusqu'au 25 mai 2016.
Et durant cette période,
nous ne traitions pas ceux trouvés,
car ils étaient déjà archivés,
nous avons traité tous ceux arrivant à partir du 28 janvier 2015.
Et nous en connaissions les itinéraires.
Durant les 16 mois de ce projet, pas un seul kit de viol n'a été égaré.
Pas un seul.
Nous savions où ils étaient.
(Applaudissements)
Ce projet continua jusqu'à ce que l’État du Michigan,
les élus du gouvernement fédéral,
aient pris connaissance du travail d'UPS.
Et tout le travail de mon bureau.
Ils ont alors décidé d'allouer des fonds de l'État
pour développer un système de traçabilité global,
Pas seulement à Détroit, mais à l'échelle de l'État.
On espère que ce système sera bientôt prêt et en place.
J'ai adoré travailler avec UPS.
J'ai adoré leur capacité d'innovation, leur rapidité de travail,
j'ai adoré leur approche singulière pour résoudre un problème simple
dont la solution devrait être simple.
Donc, après avoir travaillé avec eux,
je savais que même une seule entreprise,
travaillant sur un seul problème,
pouvait changer les choses.
On y travaille maintenant depuis neuf ans.
Cela fait donc neuf ans
que nous avons sauvé ces tests de viol de l’entrepôt.
L'entrepôt a par la suite été démoli.
Mais tous ces tests sont soit analysés,
soit à la fin de la procédure d'analyse.
Nous avons encore beaucoup à faire
en termes d'investigation et de poursuite judiciaire dans ces affaires,
mais en ce qui concerne les kits, le travail sur l'analyse est fini.
Au 28 juin 2018,
le CODIS a permis de trouver et d'identifier 2 600 suspects.
861 violeurs en série ont été identifiés.
Dans ce projet seulement.
Cela veut dire 861 potentiels accusés
qui ont violé deux fois ou plus certaines de nos victimes.
Entre 50 et 75 % d'entre eux ont violé entre 10 à 15 fois,
dans une même ville, un même État.
De plus, les résultats CODIS
ont des rapports avec des scènes de crime,
des liens dans 40 États américains.
40 des 50 États sont liés aux crimes concernés par ces tests de viols.
De l'Alaska à la Floride
et du Maine jusqu'au sud de la Californie.
D'un océan à l'autre, il existe des liens établis par le CODIS.
Natasha a maintenant 36 ans.
Quand elle a pris connaissance de notre projet concernant les tests,
elle nous a contactés, le bureau du procureur du comté de Wayne.
Son test avait finalement été analysé.
Il avait permis d'identifier Paul Warwick.
Pendant ce temps, cet homme a violé deux autres femmes.
Dont une dans le Colorado.
Paul Warwick purge maintenant, au sein d'un pénitencier du Michigan,
une peine de 15 à 40 ans de prison.
(Applaudissements)
Le test de viol de Pamela a aussi été analysé.
Son test a eu un résultat dans le CODIS qui a permis l'identification
de Bernard Peterson.
Pendant ce temps, Bernard Peterson a violé 10 autres femmes.
Chacune de ces 10 femmes avait fait un test de viol.
Tous leurs tests de viol étaient restés stockés avec celui de Pamela.
Pendant un certain nombre d'années.
Cet homme purge aujourd'hui une peine,
dans le Michigan,
simultanément, en même temps,
de 60 à 90 ans, et de 90 à 125 ans,
pour les viols qu'il a commis.
(Applaudissements)
On a encore du pain sur la planche.
Et on a vraiment besoin du secteur privé.
On a besoin de l'industrie technologique.
Pour développer, pas pour nous aider, mais pour qu'eux développent,
des systèmes de gestion de l'information,
pour avoir une communication efficace
et arrêter ces agresseurs
qui violent, mutilent et tuent en toute impunité.
Nous avons également besoin de ceux d'entre vous
ayant des compétences en marketing et publicité.
On a besoin de vous, désespérément,
pour créer des campagnes et faire entendre notre message aux enfants et à tous,
pour mettre un terme à la culture du viol, arrêter la culpabilisation des victimes
qui ont trop peur de s'exprimer à cause de ce qui pourrait leur arriver.
UPS n'était qu'une seule entreprise.
Ils nous ont aidés grâce à leur innovation
et ont révolutionné la manière dont on peut pister ces tests.
Tous les aspects de nos vies sont pistés.
Tous nos likes, nos humeurs,
nos achats, nos recherches internet, nos lectures,
notre historique internet tout entier est pisté de nos jours.
Qu'adviendrait-il si on pouvait traquer les activités et les allées et venues
des criminels ?
Tout comme on traque tous les aspects de notre vie.
En 2015, le gouvernement d'Obama
et le Ministère de la Justice
ont estimé le nombre de tests de viol non-testés à 400 000,
à travers les États-Unis.
400 000.
C'est une épidémie nationale.
Pour la plupart, on sait où ils sont.
Nos tests ont démontré
que les femmes étaient violées dans leur voiture, en attendant des amis,
en allant ou en revenant du travail,
dans des stations essence, dans des centres commerciaux.
Parmi les premiers cas traités,
alors qu'on commençait les analyses,
un homme est rentré dans une maison par la fenêtre
et a violé une femme, dans son lit, à côté de ses deux enfants.
Il l'a violée alors qu'elle était au lit avec ses deux enfants.
À chaque fois que je vois une victime de viol qui vient dans mon bureau,
parce que leur cas avance,
qu'elle témoigne devant le procureur
ou qu'elle se prépare pour le procès,
je la regarde dans les yeux et je me dis :
« Ça n'aurait jamais dû lui arriver. »
Elle n'aurait jamais dû être l'une de ces victimes.
Elle ne le serait peut-être pas si ces tests avaient été analysés dans les temps.
Combien d'autres Pamela dans ce monde ?
Combien d'autres Natasha dans ce monde ?
On ne le saura sans doute jamais.
Mais ce que je sais, c'est que vous avez la technologie,
vous savez l'exploiter
et qu'ensemble, on peut résoudre le problème des tests non analysés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)